when Al Gore comes to South Park he
tells the kids about this deadly
creature called manbearpig and it's
going to destroy their lives and they
must they must do something about man
met manbearpig and the South Park boys
understand that man-made global warming
is a fantastical creature all I was
lucky enough to do was to go trolling
through the internet one day read the
rather wonderful website what's up with
that and realized that a very exciting
story was breaking
Climategate was a leak of emails from
the University of East Anglia what they
showed is that the scientists at the
very heart of the Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate change's reports into
into global warming that these guys were
torturing the evidence until it screamed
they were suppressing the views of
scientists with dissenting voices they
were generally behaving like very very
bad boys you know and and what these
emails suggested was hang on a second
these guys are telling us in their
reports the science is settled but how
can we trust these guys will we see what
they get up to in these emails my story
got drudged it caught the popular
imagination by the end of that week
Climategate had had 30 million google
google hits
Climategate was a game changer and at
the same time it changed absolutely
nothing let me explain
Climategate showed these scientists in
action being naughty whereas previously
there there wasn't so much evidence that
they were doing it deliberately this
caught them red-handed and that was the
first part and that's why we all got
very excited we thought well hang on a
second the scam is over it's all going
to be it then they won't dare have the
hutzpah to to carry on try to cheat us
in this
way what actually happened there were
three or was it for official inquiries
independent inquiries into Climategate
and guess what they they found the
Climategate scientists innocent of any
kind of wrongdoing nothing to see here
move along that was the message we got
from those those investigations it's not
about the science it is about politics
you know according to the theory as co2
levels anthropogenic co2 levels that is
that you know the stuff we've been
making factories and stuff as those
anthropogenic co2 levels rise
dramatically so so global temperatures
will rise with it but actually they
haven't been there's been no global
warming since 1998
well co2 hasn't stopped rising so so
then it must be slightly more
complicated than these these do mongers
are saying I think I can speak for
pretty much everyone on my side of the
argument we are not in it for the lies
we all we want is that is is for open
debate for the truth to get out if the
data real data as opposed to adjusted
data if the real data shows that the
world is getting dangerously hot and
that there is a definite connection
between anthropogenic co2 and global
warming then hey we'll start addressing
that problem because you know I mean if
it is that serious it's going to affect
us all but what we don't believe in is
this smearing and lies and this idea
that that that it is wrong simply to
even question the orthodoxy
the global warming industry is worth
trillions it's often said that the most
expensive scientific experiment in the
history of mankind was the Manhattan
Project so far in in real terms around
five times the Manhattan Project has
been spent on research into manmade
global warming you can buy a lot of
vested interests a lot of businessmen a
lot of politicians for that kind of
money I think a lot of people when
watching the no-pressure video could be
forgiven for assuming that this is a
pastiche done by people on my side of
the argument to satirize the extremist
impulses of the warmest it's nothing of
the kind
this hasn't got to be a huge thing but I
would love it if you and your families
would think about doing something what
sort of thing miss well like getting
your dad to insulate the loft or taking
your next holiday by train instead of
flying or buying energy-saving light
bulbs we're thinking of using our car
less I'm going cycle school that's
fantastic Jemima no no pressure at all
but it'd be great to get a sense of how
many of you might do just just a
percentage that's fantastic and there's
not Phillip and Tracy
that's fine that's absolutely fine your
own choice okay class thank you so much
for today and I will see you all
tomorrow you imagine if the children
were executed for being gay or or or
Muslim or something I mean can you
imagine the outcry yet these guys this
team led by Richard Curtis in The
Guardian newspaper Sony David Ginola one
of the world's top footballers was in it
was in it
Gillian Anderson from the x-files these
people they were all involved in the
project and not one of them at any stage
in the making of this video said to
themselves hang on a second are we
seriously suggesting that climate change
deniers should be executed it was quite
good to see that a lot of people who
would have been considered themselves
sympathetic to the aims of this of this
campaign you know reducing our carbon
emissions by 10% by by 2010 found
themselves sickened and perhaps to a
degree had their eyes opened to what is
going on in in in the green movement I
called the what the book watermelons ah
because they're green on the outside but
red on the inside after the Berlin Wall
came down the communist movement the
global leftist movement was left in a
bit of a quandary they'd pretty much
lost the economic argument they needed
somewhere else to go
and global warming has become the great
proxy issue it enables them to achieve
many of the same aims as before but
under a cloak of green righteousness
this book although it is about global
warming is about something in fact much
much bigger than that it is about a
global takeover by fascism communism
call it what you
will their aims are much the same it is
about it is about control there is a
very good answer
to those who say that this book sounds
like conspiracy theory and that is go
and read what the what the United
Nations says go and read what people
like Morris strong say go and read
people like Rachel Carson Paul Ehrlich
these are the heroes of the green
movement and the things they talk about
are things like the need to limit
population to control population to
reign in economic growth to preserve
scarce resources for future generations
essentially through rationing I don't
look at population and the human race
and think there is an evil that must be
eradicated as indeed one of the great
documents of the green movement says you
know the limits to growth the earth has
a cancer and the cancer is is man this
is what the Club of Rome says I don't
think man is a cancer I think that you
know by and large we are we're ok and we
do goods the planet as economic growth
happens so we have more money to spend
on cleaning up rivers on making our
environment more beautiful on making
land more productive so that we have
have to use less of it to make more food
for more people what's not to like about
that